.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Sanfte, fliessende Gitarrenmusik *
* Quietschen *
Das sind Placebo-Tabletten.
Tablette, in denen
kein Wirkstoff drin ist.
Die mussten wir schon ein paar Mal
für eine Kinderärztin herstellen,
die Kindern
Melatonin-Tabletten verschrieben hat
und sie wieder absetzen will.
Was hilft und was heilt im Leben?
Und zu welchem Preis?
Davon handelt dieser Film.
Die machst du mit der Kettensäge?
- Ja, genau.
Hier oben sind die Haken
und die Schiene.
Man muss etwas vorsichtig sein,
sonst gleiten sie nicht.
In dieser Berner Apotheke hängt
keine Werbung. Hier hängt Kunst.
Silvio Ballinari
hat seine eigenen Vorstellungen.
Kann es sich eine Apotheke heutzutage
leisten, auf Werbung zu verzichten?
Der Überkonsum von Medikamenten
ist generell ein Problem.
Das ist nicht irgendeine Konsumware.
Es gilt: Weniger ist mehr.
Und nicht umgekehrt.
Es hat keinen Sinn, möglichst
viele Medikamente zu verkaufen.
Man müsste
mit möglichst gar keinen auskommen.
Ja, so ist es gut.
- Schön.
Statt Pillen
gegen Hals- und Kopfschmerzen
Bilder
von Migranten und Migrantinnen,
hergestellt mit einer Motorsäge.
Für Silvio Ballinari
steht der Mensch im Zentrum.
Die Patienten statt der Profit.
Die Apotheke trägt deshalb
auch seine Handschrift.
Das ist selbst gemalt,
weil es mir Spass macht.
Ich male ab und zu,
und dann bin ich froh,
wenn ich solche Sachen machen kann.
Silvio Ballinari.
Er sei ein Vorbild,
gar ein vollendeter Humanist.
Das sagt der Generalsekretär
des Schweizer Apothekerverbands
pharmaSuisse über den Berner.
Ein Apotheker, der für ein
gerechteres Gesundheitssystem kämpft.
Es gibt sehr viele Ärzte,
sehr viele Apotheker,
sehr viele Forscher,
die ehrlich arbeiten
und für die Interessen
der Patienten arbeiten.
Und dann gibt es ein paar Leute
in den höheren Etagen
der Pharmaindustrie,
die nur darauf schauen,
dass das Maximum für die Shareholder
herausgeholt wird.
Und das regt mich auf.
Sie beschmutzen
das Vertrauensverhältnis
des Gesundheitswesens
in der Schweiz.
Das hat zur Folge, dass alle sagen:
"Chemie,
das will ich gar nicht schlucken,
das ist alles des Teufels."
Das stimmt nicht,
es ist nicht alles des Teufels.
Es gibt grossartige Erfindungen.
Aber wenn der, der es verkauft,
das Maximum rausholen will,
unabhängig davon,
was das für einen Patienten oder
eine ganze Patientengruppe bedeutet,
dann ist es schlimm.
Besonders aufgeregt hat er sich
vor ein paar Jahren
über eine amerikanische Pharmafirma,
die einen alten Wirkstoff
als teures Medikament verkauft.
Die Substanz Dimethylfumarat
soll bei Multipler Sklerose helfen.
Ballinari zeigte, wie er ein Mittel
mit gleichem Wirkstoff herstellt.
Er verkauft es zehnmal günstiger.
Ein kleiner, umtriebiger Apotheker,
der das grosse Geschäft
der Pharmaindustrie entlarvt.
Das sorgte für Kontroversen.
Sogar im Nationalrat
war davon die Rede.
Unser Produkt
ist der gleiche Wirkstoff.
Es ist magensaftresistent.
Und wir haben inzwischen mehrere
Jahre Erfahrung mit den Patienten.
Thomas Cueni, Geschäftsführer
des Branchenverbands Interpharma.
Die Krankenkassenprämien steigen,
aber mit solchen Medikamenten
könnte man
den Kostenanstieg dämpfen.
Sind Sie auch dafür?
Wenn ich sehe,
wie der Apotheker im Hinterzimmer
von Hand die Tabletten herstellt,
fällt mir nur ein:
Wenn drei Personen mit dem
gleichen Rezept einen Kuchen backen
und diesen in den Ofen schieben,
gibt es trotzdem
drei verschiedene Kuchen.
Wir haben aber eine Ärztin,
die sagt,
dass sie diese Art
von Apothekenmedikamenten
regelmässig verschreibe,
es gebe keine Probleme.
Das erstaunt mich.
Es ist nicht so, wie gesagt wurde.
Wir haben keine Daten
zur Sicherheit und Wirksamkeit
des Apothekenprodukts.
Die Pharmaindustrie würde sagen,
Sie hätten zu dem Thema
keine Studie gemacht.
Die wurde ja von ihnen gemacht.
Die hygienischen Bedingungen ...
- Die sind tadellos.
Es ist ja nicht so,
dass wir
irgendwelche Hinterhofküchen hätten.
Wir werden kontrolliert,
der Kantonsapotheker kommt vorbei
und schaut, wie wir arbeiten.
Die Hersteller sind Apotheker.
Das sind nicht
irgendwelche Angestellte.
Die wissen, was sie herstellen.
Aber so viele Produkte
aus der Pharmaindustrie,
die ja korrekt sein sollen,
mussten vom Markt genommen werden,
weil sie verunreinigt waren,
z.B. durch Nitrosamine
oder krebserregende Mittel,
weil sie am falschen Ort
eingekauft wurden.
Was sollen wir dazu sagen?
Wir arbeiten seriöser als sie.
So ist es.
Das Herstellen von Heilmitteln,
das ist seine Mission.
Silvio Ballinari will
diese Kernkompetenz der Apotheker
wieder stärken.
Dazu brauche es aber auch Ärzte,
die nicht nur Medikamentenmarken
auf das Rezept schreiben,
sondern einzelne Substanzen.
Das Wort Quacksalber ...
Das ist ein interessantes Wort.
Man assoziiert mit Quacksalber
eigentlich denjenigen, der betrügt,
der den Leuten etwas vormacht
und sagt:
"Dieses Mittel ist gut für das",
auch wenn es im Grunde genommen
nur ein Placebo ist.
Aber ob das jetzt ein Krämer ist,
der ungenau abwägt
und solche Sachen macht,
oder ob das
die Pharmaindustrie ist,
die nicht die ganze Studie
publiziert,
damit sie alles verkaufen kann
und so sehr viele Menschenleben
in Gefahr bringt -
das sind Quacksalber.
Er nimmt uns mit
in die Vergangenheit.
Apotheker müssen jede Substanz, jedes
Mittel sorgfältig dokumentieren.
Das sind die Rezeptbücher
von 1906 bis heute.
Durchgehend. Alles da.
Wenn man hier schaut ...
Das ist heute noch so:
Jedes Rezept hat eine Nummer.
Daneben stehen der Arzt,
der es verschrieben hat,
der Patient
und die Zusammensetzung
und der Preis.
Jede Rezeptur
muss eingetragen werden.
Wenn man das Ganze heute anschaut,
dann sieht es so aus:
Jede Substanz
hat eine Chargennummer,
so kann man es rückverfolgen.
Jedes Rezept, das wir herstellen,
muss bis aufs Letzte
rückverfolgbar sein.
Das ist eine schöne Leistung.
Aber es sind leider nicht mehr
so schöne Rezeptbücher,
sondern nur riesige Ordner.
Die Apotheke
hat eine langjährige Geschichte.
Es ist auch die seiner Vorfahren.
Denn Silvio Ballinari hat den Beruf
von seinen Eltern geerbt.
Die hat meine Mutter angeschrieben.
Die kann ich nicht wegwerfen,
ganz klar.
Rein emotionell,
denn ich brauche sie nicht mehr.
Hier sind z.B. ...
Zuoberst.
Das sind Tonkabohnen.
Hier ist noch
das Etikett von Kaiser dran,
also vom Begründer der Apotheke.
Das ist vielleicht 100 Jahre alt,
was hier drin ist.
Seit 130 Jahren
in der Berner Länggasse.
Die Zähringer Apotheke
ist die älteste Quartierapotheke
der Stadt Bern.
Vater Ballinari - hier mit Sohn
Silvio - übernimmt sie 1944.
Die Mutter Neuenburgerin,
der Vater Tessiner.
Zwei von vier Kindern
werden später selbst Apotheker.
Vater und Sohn teilen den Beruf,
doch nicht die Überzeugung.
Sein Vater habe der Pharmaindustrie
noch sehr vertraut.
Er konsumierte selbst viel davon
und er fand,
es sei ein Segen,
dass es all diese Medikamente gebe.
Er sah nichts Schlechtes dahinter.
Er hat allerdings noch
zu einer anderen Zeit gelebt.
Das war
in den 40er- und 50er-Jahren.
Damals konnte er noch nicht
alles wissen, was ich jetzt weiss.
1981 übernimmt Silvio Ballinari
das Geschäft von seinen Eltern,
zusammen mit seiner damaligen Frau.
Es gibt viele Apothekerpaare.
Ich weiss ehrlich gesagt nicht,
ob ich es empfehlen würde.
Was wir getan haben,
war insofern sehr interessant,
da wir zwei Kinder adoptierten.
Wir teilten uns
genau hälftig die Arbeit,
also nach 14 Tagen
ging einer nach Hause
und kümmerte sich um die Kinder
und der andere ging in die Apotheke.
Man wusste immer,
was der andere macht.
Das ist etwas belastend
für eine Beziehung,
weil man sich
nicht mehr viel zu sagen hat,
wenn beide das Gleiche tun.
* "These Are The Days"
von Van Morrison *
# There is no past,
there's only future.
# ... only future.
# There's only here.
# There's only now.
Dabei ist er einer, der viel zu sagen
hat, weil ihn viel interessiert.
Er ist nicht nur Apotheker, sondern
auch Künstler, Philosoph, Musiker.
Ein buntes Leben, das nicht immer
in geraden Bahnen verläuft.
Kommt er hier an, kommt er zur Ruhe:
Das Atelier seines
argentinischen Künstlerfreundes
ist für den Apotheker
ein Ort der Inspiration.
Silvio.
Wow, che nuovi quadri che hai fatto.
Sì, certo.
Er malt oft. Heute sind es Etiketten
für Produkte in seiner Apotheke.
Warum sind Sie Apotheker geworden
und nicht etwas Kreativeres?
Mir gefällt es,
dass wir für unseren Beruf
etwas kämpfen müssen.
Wir werden z.T.
gar nicht richtig wahrgenommen
und auch nicht
so richtig ernst genommen.
Wenn wir etwas erreichen wollen,
müssen wir etwas dafür tun.
Silvio Ballinari macht viel im Leben,
und das mit Leidenschaft -
bis er selbst
Risiken und Nebenwirkungen spürt.
Das war vor sieben Jahren.
Wenn ich das sehe, dann kommt mir
der Herzinfarkt in den Sinn.
Das sind die Herzkranzgefässe.
An einem Ort ist ein Unterbruch
und es ist verstopft.
Das hat dann eine wahnsinnige
Wirkung auf den ganzen Körper.
Man erschrickt natürlich.
Obschon, ich bin ja ein Hypochonder
und habe das Gefühl:
"Oh, jetzt habe ich das und das."
Aber vielleicht
ist es auch ein wenig Kokettieren,
dass ich sage:
"Ich habe das und das."
Und als ich
dieses komische Gefühl hatte,
sagte ich zu meiner Freundin, dass
ich wohl einen Herzinfarkt habe.
Sie sagte:
"Bitte nicht schon wieder."
Ich hatte ja vorher nie einen.
Aber dieses Mal merkte ich,
dass irgendwas nicht gut war.
Ich ging zum Arzt,
als es wieder kam.
Er machte sofort ein EKG gemacht
und schickte mich ins Krankenhaus,
weil es eben doch einer war.
Er hat Glück. Aber nicht immer.
2018 erkrankt seine
langjährige Lebenspartnerin schwer.
Der Tod selbst ist sehr schlimm,
weil es so definitiv ist.
Auf der anderen Seite:
Jemanden neben sich zu haben, der
schwer erkrankt ist und leiden muss,
schien mir persönlich
das Schlimmere zu sein.
Zu erleben, wie sie ...
... gar nicht mehr
richtig atmen konnte.
Sie hatte Lungenkrebs.
Das ...
Das hat mich fertiggemacht.
Das war wirklich schlimm.
Was hilft und was heilt im Leben?
Das weiss auch ein Apotheker
nicht immer.
Wie war das?
Sie war krank
und es gab kein Mittel, das ihr half.
Was ich jetzt sage, ist delikat.
Ich bin der Meinung,
ohne fatalistisch sein zu wollen:
Es gibt nicht für alles ein Mittel.
Wenn man bedenkt, wie banal es ist:
Man nimmt etwas ein
und das macht einen gesund.
Das stimmt
in der Regel einfach nicht.
Man nimmt ein Mittel ein
und das bewirkt im Körper etwas,
sodass der Körper wieder seine
Energie, seine Lebenskraft findet
und so gesund werden kann.
Er selbst hat
seine Lebensenergie wiedergefunden.
Eine neue Liebe kann heilsam sein.
Ich bin jemand, der nicht lange
an die Vergangenheit denkt:
"Oh, ich bin so arm!"
Vielleicht trauere ich
nicht lange genug. Das stimmt.
Ich gehe einfach wieder vorwärts.
Vielleicht habe ich das
etwas zu schnell gemacht.
Aber ich bin ganz sicher,
wenn sie mitbestimmen könnte,
würde es sie eher freuen,
dass es mir gut geht, als umgekehrt.
Silvio Ballinari
ist kein Kind von Traurigkeit.
Einige Wochen bevor Corona
das Zusammensein verändert,
lädt er mit seiner Band zum Tanz.
Der Alt-68er
glaubt an den Wirkstoff Musik.
Musik ist heilsam für die,
die sie machen, ganz sicher.
Und wenn Leute sich begegnen
und zusammen tanzen,
dann ist das etwas Heilsames.
Er hat in den 70er-Jahren das
Folkfestival Lenzburg organisiert,
einen Vorläufer
des heutigen Gurtenfestivals.
* Sie spielen ein fröhliches Lied. *
Die Band Tutti Frutti
spielt seit fast 40 Jahren zusammen.
Jahrelang war auch Ballinaris
Lebenspartnerin als Musikerin dabei.
Das war ein herber Verlust.
Am Anfang ...
... dachte ich,
wir können nicht mehr weitermachen.
Aber es geht halt einfach weiter.
Aber sie fehlt?
- Ja, ja.
Man tröstet sich halt.
Jetzt kommt noch meine Liebste.
Heute kommen auch seine neue
Partnerin und seine Tochter.
Hallo, Jole.
Es ist kalt.
Seit ich mich erinnern kann,
seit ich ein Kind war,
machte er immer Musik
und war natürlich auch oft weg.
Z.T. war das nicht so lustig.
Aber ich genoss es immer sehr
an den Familienfesten,
wenn er Musik machte -
das war im kleineren Rahmen.
Ich kenne nichts anderes, mein Vater
hat immer viele Menschen um sich.
Alle, die er kennt.
Hier ist er in seinem Element.
# Femmena,
tu si na malafemmena.
# Chist'uocchie 'e fatto chiagnere
# acreme e 'nfamità.
lacreme e 'nfamità.
# Femmena,
si tu peggio 'e na vipera.
# M'e 'ntussecata l'anema.
Es ist eine Liebeserklärung
an die Menschen.
Ich muss es so sagen.
Vielleicht bin dafür
im familiären Rahmen
oder in der Zweierkiste
etwas weniger brauchbar.
Das könnte ich mir noch vorstellen.
Als Tochter, als Kind allgemein,
will man einfach,
dass Papi und Mami oft zu Hause sind
und dass man selber
Priorität Nummer 1 ist.
Und das war ich nicht so, weil
er als Selbstständiger arbeitet
und deswegen auch viel weg war.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Merci.
Es ist März 2020 - ein Frühling
für die Geschichtsbücher.
Schweizerinnen und Schweizer
decken sich millionenfach
mit Medikamenten ein.
Wegen COVID-19
gehen in diesem Monat
40 % mehr Medikamentenpackungen
über den Apothekenladentisch
als im März vor einem Jahr.
Sein gemaltes Etikett
ist fertig geworden -
für einen antiviralen Tee.
Passend zur Corona-Zeit.
Grüessech.
Hast du Interesse an Masken,
die man 25-mal waschen kann?
Wie viel kostet eine Packung?
Für Sie 4 Euro das Stück.
Also 20 Fr.
Ich lasse die hier
und Sie können es sich überlegen.
Alles klar.
- Danke. Bleiben Sie gesund.
Gleichfalls.
- Danke.
Das war schon der Dritte
heute Morgen,
der uns Masken für den Weiterverkauf
verkaufen will.
* Er lacht. *
Es gab ja das
mit der Unterhose als Maske.
Diese hier sieht ganz ähnlich aus.
Aber sie ist nicht schlecht.
Sind Sie für eine Maskenpflicht?
Ich bin in der Regel
nicht für Pflichten,
denn wenn ich
zu etwas verpflichtet werde,
dann mache ich es
garantiert nicht.
Aber ich bin der Meinung, dass die
Massnahmen, die getroffen wurden,
auch diese Strenge des Bundesrates,
gut sind.
Ich finde es richtig,
dass man mit diesen Massnahmen
mehr darauf achtet,
dass die Gesundheit
der älteren Leute geschützt wird,
als dass das Gewerbe geschützt wird.
Ich finde es richtig, und
das müssen wir aushalten können.
Während man sich drinnen
auf eine Extremsituation einstellt,
ist draussen im Garten der Apotheke
von Hektik nichts zu spüren.
So ist es gut.
Diese Schildkröten
beenden ihre Winterruhe.
Ballinaris Nichten helfen mit,
sie zu wecken.
Das ist Kamillenextrakt,
wie Kamillosan.
Das haben schon meine Eltern
ins Wasser gegeben.
Das ist gut,
man badet ja auch die Kinder.
Das ist gut.
Ist das ein jährliches Ritual?
Klar, sonst wissen die Leute nicht,
wann Frühling ist.
Sie sehen die Schildkröten draussen:
Jetzt ist Frühling.
Manche dieser Tiere
sind über 70 Jahre alt.
1944 kaufte Vater Ballinari
drei griechische Landschildkröten.
Ob er das getan hat,
weil er Freude an Schildkröten hatte
oder weil er einen Kundenfänger
wollte, weiss ich nicht.
Auf alle Fälle
wurden die Kunden angelockt.
Die Kunden kamen mit ihren Kindern
und die Kinder sagten,
sie wollen eine Schildkröte,
also kaufte man eine Schildkröte.
Aber die Kinder wurden älter
und die Schildkröten waren im Weg.
Dann sagten die Leute:
"Wir wissen nicht,
was wir mit den Schildkröten
machen sollen."
"Dürfen wir sie Ihnen geben?"
Eine Weile lang hatten wir 33 Stück.
Ich dachte nur,
das nimmt ja verrückte Ausmasse an.
Ab und zu verschenkte ich eine.
Es kamen ständig
Leute in den Laden,
die nach einer Schildkröte fragten.
Aber irgendwann
war Schluss mit Verschenken.
Es ist natürlich schön.
Es sind wirklich schöne Tiere,
ich kann das gut begreifen.
Sie haben so etwas
Entschleunigendes,
was in der heutigen Zeit
noch gut ist.
Entschleunigen -
das macht Silvio Ballinari
nun nach und nach
auch in der kleinen Apotheke.
14 Personen
arbeiten in seinem Geschäft.
Für die Nachfolge ist es wichtig,
dass jemand
diesen Stil weiterführen kann.
Mit Stil meine ich:
Es gibt zwei Labors.
Wir haben uns in den letzten Jahren
auf die Herstellung konzentriert
und wir müssen das können, was
die Kettenapotheken nicht können.
Wir haben keine grosse Ladenfläche.
Unsere Qualität ist nicht die Ware,
die wir haben.
Unsere Qualität ist das,
was wir herstellen können,
und das, was wir empfehlen können.
Der Mensch im Zentrum.
Das bedeutet
für den Idealisten Ballinari auch,
dass er als Arbeitgeber
ein Zeichen setzen will
und Asylbewerberinnen
eine Chance gibt.
Wenn die Leute hier sagen:
"Wir geben
nur noch den Schweizern ..."
Eben Inländervorrang -
dann muss ich sagen,
es ist irgendwie
eine Beleidung für das Menschsein,
dass man den einen
keine Chance gibt,
nur weil sie von der anderen Seite
der Grenze kommen
und nicht
von dieser Seite der Grenze.
Das ist wirklich Dummheit.
Und die Erfahrung zeigt,
wenn wir hier zusammen Pause machen,
dann haben sie sich
etwas zu erzählen.
Wenn alle gleich sind, dann
hat man sich nicht viel zu erzählen.
Für uns ist das ist eine Qualität.
Wir profitieren alle davon,
dass wir Vielfalt haben.
Ich bekam immer Absagen.
Ich hatte keine Chance
als Pharmaassistentin.
Dann ...
... kam ich hierher.
Und er sagte mir:
"Ja, du bekommst die Stelle."
Ich hatte solche Freude, wirklich.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt
war die junge Syrerin
in der Schweiz
bloss vorläufig aufgenommen.
Es ist ein Risiko, das stimmt.
Nun haben wir auch wieder jemanden,
der plötzlich einen
negativen Entscheid bekommen hat,
obwohl die ganze Familie
schon seit drei Jahren hier ist.
Dann muss man auf die Hinterbeine
stehen und sagen:
"Wir müssen etwas
dagegen unternehmen."
Widerstand leisten,
Alternativen bieten.
Das will er auch
als pharmakritischer Apotheker.
Ein befreundeter Botaniker
möchte Chörblichrut neu herstellen,
ein altes, fast vergessenes
Allerweltsmittel aus dem Emmental.
Das fasziniert mich.
Es gibt
viele pflanzliche Arzneimittel,
die aus den Arzneibüchern
rausgenommen wurden,
weil man sagte,
dass sie nichts nützen.
Und erst viel später
stellte man fest,
dass es eben trotzdem nützt.
Es ist natürlich klar ...
Wer setzt sich schon dafür ein,
um zu beweisen,
dass das Chörblichrut-Wasser
wirklich etwas bringt?
Keiner -
da steht keine Lobby dahinter,
keine Industrie,
die eine Studie zahlen könnte.
Aber man muss es ja nicht verbieten,
nur weil es nicht
als Medikament zugelassen ist.
Das hier ist die erste
"Schweizerische Pharmakopöe",
soweit ich weiss,
aus dem Kanton Bern.
Tentamen Bernensis, von 1852.
Ich hatte mir überlegt,
wenn das Chörblichrut-Wasser
so eine Tradition hat,
dann muss es logischerweise
auch in der Pharmakopöe sein,
wenn es wirklich
als Heimmittel eingesetzt wurde.
Und es ist tatsächlich hier drin.
Es gab es wirklich.
Es wurde im 19. Jh. anscheinend
immer von den Bauern benutzt.
Noch heute pflanzen Emmentaler Bauern
Chörblichrut an.
Ballinari
soll für den Botaniker überprüfen,
ob das daraus gewonnene
aromatische Wasser
gesundheitlich unbedenklich ist.
Es riecht wunderbar.
Die Pflanze
holt er bei einem Biobauern.
Trinkst du auch Chörblichrut?
Selten.
Das machen eher die älteren Leute.
Mein Grossvater wurde
letzten Dezember 100 Jahre alt,
der kennt es gut.
Der wurde deswegen 100 Jahre alt!
- Vielleicht.
Es ist interessant.
Schulmedizinisch wird das Blut,
wie man sagt, verdünnt.
Volksmedizinisch sagt man oft:
Blutreinigung.
Das ist natürlich Mist,
es gibt keine Blutreinigung.
Wir sind nicht dreckig.
Aber man kann es verdünnen.
Und dazu nimmt man ...
Sehr oft nimmt man dann
prophylaktisch
Aspirin und Ähnliches ein,
um das Blut zu verdünnen.
Wenn man nun statt Aspirin
Chörblichrut-Wasser nehmen könnte,
wäre das ein Hit.
Das Kraut lassen der Botaniker
und der Apotheker
bei einem Bauern destillieren.
Silvio ist ein Tausendsassa,
der kann alles.
Er ist auch ein wenig ein Rebell.
Ich ging an seine Konzerte -
er ist ja Multitasker
und spielt mit seiner Band.
Ich durfte einige Konzerte
von Tutti Frutti erleben.
Und ich erinnerte mich an ihn,
als ich einen Apotheker suchte,
der das Chörblichrut
sozusagen mit dem wissenschaftlichen
Siegel versehen konnte.
Die frisch geschnittenen Stauden
sieden im Wasserdampf des Brennofens.
Das alkoholfreie Kondensationswasser
sammelt sich
und tröpfelt Stunden später
durch die Rohre in den Behälter.
Noch schmeckt das Chörblichrut-Wasser
eher nach schlechtem Pastis.
Gesundheit.
- Prost.
Es ist mir noch zu wässerig.
Ja, das finde ich auch.
Es dürfte stärker sein.
Alles, was wir machen,
ist ein Tüfteln und Ausprobieren.
Auch in unseren Beziehungen.
Man denkt sich:
"Was ist das für einer?"
Und dann probiert man es so
und dann so.
Je nachdem, wie der andere reagiert,
reagiert man selber darauf.
Ich sagte das ja schon
wegen der Medikamente.
Es sind nicht die Stoffe,
die uns gesund machen,
sondern es sind
die Reaktionen auf die Stoffe,
die eine Veränderung bringen.
Wenn man jemandem begegnet,
in den man verliebt ist,
und sie zwinkert einem zu,
dann gibt das
eine körperliche Reaktion.
Das kann man
chemisch und physikalisch messen.
Und trotzdem ist
kein Molekül rübergegangen,
es ist nur ein kleiner Reiz.
Es ist nicht eine Melodie,
die uns gesund macht.
Sondern die Melodie, die wir hören,
macht, dass wir beschwingt sind,
und das verändert etwas
in unserem Körper.
Das ist das Entscheidende.
# This is the love
of the one magician ...
Was hilft und was heilt im Leben?
Dieser Apotheker würde sagen,
es ist nicht bloss das Mittel,
sondern auch das,
was wir im Leben daraus machen.
* Er pfeift die Melodie. *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Alexandra Duttweiler - 2020
# These are the days.